Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. This is more perfect right now.
Bossy here is working madly on a story about a supreme court case that will be
decided any minute to one of the most important supreme court cases this term
maybe of my lifetime, but in the meantime,
I wanted to share something with you guys as you maybe know that this podcast,
this new podcast you're listening to more perfect is radio labs first ever spin
off the episode for me,
the radio lab episode for me that inspired me to try out this whole series.
It actually goes back to 2012 it was our first time ever reporting about the
supreme court.
I asked the entire team at radio lab to look at the docket for that year,
pick a case, make a few calls with sort of an [inaudible]
bear man, reporter Tim Howard came back with the following story.
It's about a little girl who becomes the center of a very big fight.
This is the story that got us hooked on thinking about the Supreme Court and in
many ways it inspired us to make more perfect.
Here's Tim. So I first, I first heard about this story, um,
I saw it listed on the supreme court docket for cases that they were going to be
hearing this spring. Well,
the name of the case is baby girl versus adoptive couple.
Actually in strict legal parlance, it's called adoptive couple v baby girl.
It's not a particularly catchy name. I've got to say it's a weird name though.
It's hard to, it's hard to picture. Yeah. So this is Marcia Zuck,
associate professor of law at the University of South Carolina and she wrote
about this case in slate and it stood out to me because, you know,
it just seemed odd at first that this would even be a supreme court case.
It seemed more like a, a straight forward custody case. Right.
But when you dig in, yeah, there's a lot going on here. Crusades,
text messages, state law cares, children, Supreme Court,
Christopher Columbus Christian curriculum.
And it is not straight forward at all. Apparently not.
So let me walk you through it. The way that I learned about it.
The story begins with a couple, Matt and Melanie, capital Bianco. Um,
they are a couple who live down here in South Carolina.
He's a technician at Boeing. She's a developmental psychologist,
nice middle class, white couple. They're in their late thirties.
And you really wanted to have a kid. They had gone through, uh, you know,
infertility problems. It wasn't working out.
So eventually they decided to adopt,
enter a woman named Chrissy Maldonado. She lives about a thousand miles away.
I believe she's in Oklahoma. She's in her twenties,
already has a couple of kids.
She's pregnant and decides that she wants to give the baby up for adoption.
And she picks the Capitol Bianco's and everyone seems happy.
A Capitol Bianco's get the baby. And they name her. Veronica.
We used to call her boss lady. Not a lot.
Most of the time of his family called her that. Yeah,
Bosley nice as everybody around. This is Matt and Melanie Capobianco.
We're happy to do whatever she told you to do. Just, yeah,
the a poster child for a proud father, you know,
but
it's just gone as as wrong as it could have possibly gone.
[inaudible]
this is basically how it unfolded on TV news bracken session on the docket
today.
A young child ripped from the arms of the only parents that she's ever known and
turned over to the native American biological father. She has never met a man.
Veronica had never even met. What happened is when Veronica was two,
her biological dad turned up seemingly out of nowhere,
and according to these clips, hadn't been around for two years,
had it been in the child, and now he's asking for custody and he gets it.
And the court is making them stand by and just let it happen.
W Y well, it's mainly because of this law. Indian Child Welfare Act,
the 1978 the Indian Child Welfare Act, Dustin, the dad, he's Cherokee.
He's a part of the Cherokee nation.
So that makes his daughter Veronica eligible to be Cherokee.
And the law is designed to keep Indian families together.
It gives preference to Indian kids staying with Indian parents.
So even though he'd actually signed papers, agreeing to the adoption,
he was able to invoke this law and get custody of Veronica.
He signed his custody away and he was able to then use his chair keenness to
reverse the rights. He signed away. Just hang on. All right,
cause all gonna make sense. Okay. But he takes the kid.
That's what you're saying. Yeah. New Year's Eve,
2011 with camera's rolling. Dustin Brown drives his pickup truck
into Charleston, not in melody capital beyond go clutch to two-year-old.
Veronica,
this could possibly be the last time they hold their baby as her mom and dad.
Then that evening Veronica is transferred to Dustin.
It didn't feel like we had enough time for her to be not afraid when she would
want to work strangers. Yet when she's, I mean to her,
they're complete strangers and I can't imagine that she's not going to be
terrified.
And as Dustin gets into the truck holding his two year old daughter for the
first time, a reporter asks him,
it's in her best interest.
And this is all you hear from.
I don't think so. We need to give her a thing.
Have you ever seen the child?
They declined any further comment on camera?
He gets into the truck with Veronica and they drive away back to Oklahoma.
Can I do, can I ask you what, what was the,
when was the last time that you spoke with Veronica?
It was the day after, um, the day after the
transfer. Transfer. A phone call to her. Yeah,
we spoke to her for about two minutes. [inaudible] we uh,
[inaudible] I told her we loved her and she said,
I love you mommy and I love you daddy. And I don't know,
just a few minutes and [inaudible] but that was it.
That was the last time we were able to be in touch. And that
was 16 months ago.
And how long was Veronica with them again before this happened? About two years.
Oh man, that's hard. Yeah. And you know,
when I first heard about this case, that's basically the,
the only way I thought of it, you know, is just, yeah,
that's a crazy injustice.
That's basically all I saw in it. I mean,
if you're someone who has no background in this,
then you see a case like the baby Veronica case and you're like, whoa,
where's this coming from? How can this possibly be okay?
That's Marsha Zog again,
in her article for sleek kind of caught me off guard because the title was doing
what's best for the tribe.
Two year old Veronica was ripped from the only home she's ever known.
The court made the right decision. Yeah. So I called up tasker, like,
what do you mean by that?
One of the things that's I think important to realize is that the problems that
equity was intended to address didn't stop happening that long ago.
[inaudible]
and this is where the story turned into the biggest rabbit hole I've ever fallen
into. Wait, what did she tell you? I mean,
Marsha basically said the only way you can begin to wrap your mind around what's
right and what's wrong in this story is to go back to the sixties.
Alright. How are you doing? How are you Tim?
Great to meet you and to this guy per Hirsch. Um, I'm a lawyer.
He lives in Long Island now, which is where I visited him. But in 1967,
the fall of 67,
I was on the staff of the Association on American Indian affairs,
sort of a legal advocacy group for American Indians.
And he traveled all over or working with different tribes. And um,
one day he gets a phone call from this guy, Louis Goodhouse,
the tribal chair of the devil's Lake Sioux tribe in North Dakota.
And this guy says, I really need your help. He said there was a child,
a devil's Lake Kid,
one of ours that was just abruptly taken away by social workers.
The Benson County,
North Dakota Social Services Agency came in and they took little Ivan Brown away
from his grandmother who was six.
What was their stated reason for taking a Ivan away neglect?
Because what? Because grandma wasn't, wasn't around. No.
Actually Burt says that the social workers were looking for that classic nuclear
family, biological mother, biological father children.
So when they saw him with an older relative, but no mom or dad, they thought,
oh, and they took them away.
The tribal council was extremely upset by this.
They wanted to fight a battle about this. Burt took the case,
fought it in court. We won that case. By the way, Mrs Alex Forney,
she got Ivan back after somewhat protracted battle,
but he began to wonder how widespread is this?
So from 67 to the end of 68 into 69 he tribe after
tribe, after tribe doing interviews, and he says that everywhere he went,
he would hear these stories.
I remember it vividly.
This is Deb wells. She's a member of the Rosebud Sioux tribe,
and when she was 10 years old, a car pulled into her driveway.
I'm gonna come driving in social workers and they got out of car and I told my
brothers and sisters, I said, go hike.
And they had to drag us out from underneath beds.
We got around and got in the house,
but then they took us to bluff and put us in a foster home.
It was horrible.
This was just part of every native family's history. This is Marla Jean,
big boy. She grew up on the Pine Ridge reservation in South Dakota.
I remember when I was young,
we'd go to one of the border towns and my grandma would say,
stay in the car. Lock yourself in.
Don't get out of the car and going into the trading post because they're going
to steal you. Yeah.
What we found is that on every reservation,
my name is Michael Evans, no heart. I am a [inaudible].
I Lakota from standing rock reservation.
You couldn't not find a family that didn't know of a child in placement.
Social services came and took me and my sister and told my mother and dad that
they were taking us into Bowbridge for physical tickets and they never let us
back.
Wow. Michael says that his dad spent the next 30 years looking for him.
In any case, Burt would ask these people that he was interviewing,
what reason did the social workers give you for taking the child?
And the answer is that it got ran. The gamut. Conditions of poverty, alcoholism,
overcrowding. Maybe they don't have adequate ventilation in the house.
No indoor plumbing,
but in most cases he says the reasons wouldn't have stood up in court.
They would put papers in front of them and they would sign.
They didn't know what they were signing. Some families, if they could,
they tried to fight it, but they usually couldn't afford to. Oh, look,
the tribal people are poor. So, uh,
we began to do a statistical collection of data state by state asking how many
Indian kids are in foster
foster care and adoptive placement and institutional placement,
juvenile facilities.
What do you arrived at at the end of that analysis is pretty shocking though.
[inaudible] about one third of Indian children were in out of home placements in
non-Indian settings. Hold on one third,
25 to 35% of Indian children nationwide.
We're in out of home placement
it. That's a real number. That is the real number.
That's the number you see cited again and again.
Nobody connected the dots.
Everybody thought that it was their own personal tragedy.
Nobody realized that this was a pattern and a practice that was decimating these
tribes. Wait a second.
How would this happen on this scale? I mean like would this,
is this shit bunch of social workers making
the same decision independently or is it like a policy? Well,
this is basically social workers very much acting in the spirit of the day
because you have to keep in mind that in the fifties and sixties
[inaudible]
you have all these government policies that are put in place whose entire
purpose is basically to try to once and for all solve this Indian problem that's
gone on and on.
You've got this guy in 1953 he was a senator from Utah who starts basically
trying to terminate the tribes. You mean like take away their sovereignty? Yeah,
he goes tribe to tribe trying to convince them or force them.
Tell them they have no, there's no way out of it.
He argues that this will be best for all of them. I remember this.
This was like out of e pluribus unum like to integrate them into the whole,
they will melt into the wider culture. That's what will save them.
Part of this was part of the social workers that were working in this period.
They were working under the auspices of this thing called the Indian adoption
project,
which was very much about that idea of like you take these kids from their poor
conditions and you connect them directly to white families that are looking to
adopt. So part of this was definitely top-down, very much.
In any case,
the end result of this is that a third of these kids are being taken away.
There were literally communities where there were no children.
That's Terry Cross.
He's the executive director of the National Indian Child Welfare Association in
Minnesota. There were communities where there were no children in Alaska.
There were communities where there were no children. I mean, what is,
what does the culture, except you know,
the ideas and traditions that you pass onto your kids? That's Marcia Zog. Again,
if you are hemorrhaging your children, then you're going to disappear. So what,
what do you do? Well, it's too massive a problem if you're trying to fight, uh,
all these removals of kids on a case by case basis.
Forget about it on national laws needed.
So Burt spent years walking the halls of Congress,
literally endless lobbying, congressional hearings until finally,
the Indian Child Welfare Act is passed by Congress in 1978. So it does a lot.
But basically when it comes to adoptions, the ECO has placement preferences.
So the first preference would be with the immediate family.
So you're removed from mom, you're placed with dad,
or maybe with grandmother if they say no.
Second preference would be someone else in the tribe.
And the third a is any other American Indian. Wow. Any other, yeah.
And then after that, uh, then the child can be placed with, you know,
another family. Well,
so if you're white and you're trying to adopt an Indian kid, you,
you have a lot of roadblocks. Yes. But by and large,
most of us think that equals probably the,
the best federal Indian law ever passed.
It did the most to help Indian tribes respect tribal sovereignty and really
fulfill the United States as trust relationship, uh,
with American Indian people. But now because of this case,
[inaudible]
that law may be in jeopardy.
we'll continue in a moment.
[inaudible]
Hey, party people is your girl Phoebe Robinson.
And I'm chilling with my girl Alana glaze. Uh,
what up potheads we're back with season three of our hip hop casts zone.
Many white guys from w NYC studios.
And each week I interview some of the biggest pop culture icons at Oh yeah,
they aren't straight white dudes. Yes. They get plenty of attention already.
This season I'm coming at you with cannot miss conversations from people like
black lives matter activist Deray McKesson, famous feminist, Gloria Steinem,
and queen of all Queens aqua feed her. I love all of them.
There's a lot of love on this podcast. So scratch is so many white guys.
Wherever you get your podcasts. Love you mean it. Why Keye
I'm Jad Abumrad this is more perfect. We're in the middle of a story that was,
uh, our first attempt at Supreme Court reporting and uh,
it comes from reporter Tim Howard back to him.
So in April we went to this conference in Tulsa, the board directors,
council of elders, big room. There were 700 people there.
Most of them work in child welfare organizations,
in Indian communities around the country. [inaudible] native communities.
There was some traditional Cherokee drumming films, workshops,
and all anybody could talk about was this case
Baker now and how the Baby Veronica case may affect the Indian Child Welfare
Act. So please,
please do keep maybe Veronica and her family in your prayers.
Everybody was on edge. Well, I'm really worried I'm in this situation.
This is Terry Cross again and he's one of the organizers. And he told me that,
look, the couple Bianco's I feel for them,
but in what world is it okay for one family who feels they were damaged by a law
to put thousands of other children at jeopardy for their own hurt?
I can't imagine a world where that's okay.
Well, I mean it's hard for us to say that because you know,
that's not what motivated us, our daughters, what's motivating us.
W how we feel. We just feel that.
And in this case it was a beautiful law that was put into place to prevent the
breakup of paying Hamleys Indian families. And, um,
I just think it wasn't really supposed to be applied to a situation like ours.
They say, um, but we get that there's a huge historical wrong here,
but does that have to do with
us? Reminds me of, uh, arguments that happen over affirmative action weirdly.
Definitely. But here are, the details are, are so different. You know,
they say this is a law that was created to protect Indian families, right?
But here you've got a Hispanic birth mom, you've got a white couple,
and then you've got a dad who's out of the picture.
So you're not actually protecting an Indian family,
your forcibly creating a new one. Absolutely.
And in the process you're breaking up a loving home and I don't think that was
the intent of the law ever. [inaudible] my personal opinion is that,
uh, Ecuador has outlived its usefulness and causes more problems than it solves.
This is mark fiddler.
I'm one of the attorneys for Matt and Melanie Capital Bianco.
He also happens to be native American himself.
I'm an enrolled member of the Turtle Mountain Band of Chippewa Indians.
That's a reservation up in North Dakota, right on the border with Canada,
you know, so I kind of had a foot in two cultures, so to speak.
I go back to the Raz in the summer and mark actually used to argue the other
side that the most important thing was to keep Indian families together.
And that Indian kids who are placed in non-Indian homes would experience
emotional, psychological harm by being raised outside of the culture.
But then I had a case and um, I think it was 94 which gave him pause.
Uh, boy, that's a good word.
It was a case in which this young American Indian girl, uh,
Sierra wanted to be adopted by this white couple and mark opposed it,
even though on my heart hurts,
I knew that was probably not the right thing for the child.
He won the case. She was removed from the couple's home. And um,
Sierra would tell you herself, she had a shit or really rough life.
She bounced in and out of more than 20 foster homes, ran away many,
many times and got into serious trouble with the law.
And it always nagged me. Mark says, even though the tribes have suffered,
that doesn't change the fact that if you take a kid out of a loving home,
you're going to cause her real harm.
And he says that's why he took this case because the couple Bianco's you know
they are among the most loving people I know.
He said they did everything you could ask. They're just amazing people.
They met the birth mother, Christine Maldonado, when she was pregnant,
they got to know her. She felt a connection to them. That's Laurie. Miguel's,
she's represented Christie's since last year.
And they were also willing to have an open adoption. Yeah,
we still have a relationship with Christie. We, we love it to death.
And Kristie gave birth to Veronica.
They were there with her in the delivery room. I mean, the day she was born,
I cut the cord. Matt Capobianco cut the umbilical cord.
So that's such a degree of intimacy that I,
I haven't given birth twice myself.
The idea that anyone other than my husband would be in the room is kind of
scary. But it gives you some idea of how she felt about the cup of Bianco's.
Now as for Dustin Brown, Veronica, his biological dad,
a couple months before she was born, Christy,
the birth mom sent him a text message asking him if he wants to pay child
support or he wants to waive his rights. And he replied,
I'll waive my rights rather than pay a dime in child support.
Well, there's a contrast.
So in the beginning it sounds like he did not want to be a dad. Yeah.
And then actually a few months later,
he seems to make it even more official by signing a form,
agreeing to the adoption, and then he changes his mind. Yeah. You know, and,
and obviously I was wondering what was he thinking?
Because you can't avoid the fact that how you feel about this guy is going to
influence how you feel about this law. Yeah.
And so I was trying to get in touch with him. I was pestering his lawyers. Um,
you know, will he do an interview? This went on for weeks and,
and they were basically like, he doesn't want to do interviews.
He doesn't want to talk. Yeah. Yeah. He so you didn't get him.
Yeah.
Yeah. I got it. Good.
So shortly before we were going to wrap this story,
I get an email saying come to Oklahoma when
he lives in this one story house on this treeline block in a small town north of
Tulsa. Hey, how's it going? How are we doing? Good. Okay.
Are we done? What does it look like? He's just a very normal looking guy.
A little bit of an army haircut. That's real.
He had a stash that night when he got Veronica, but he's clean shaven now.
Big Smile. So anyway, we go inside and the first thing he tells me
is that Veronica is not there.
Excited to meet her or as it says she was out with his wife.
Robyn goes out with my wife, turns out he's remarried in any case to assist us.
Alright. We sat down at the kitchen table and started talking.
Do you want to just,
do you mind introducing yourself and telling me like where we are?
I'm Dustin Brown. Um, we're, I no one Oklahoma, this is my house. Um,
um, part of the wolf clan,
Wolf clan is one of the seven Cherokee clans and my name Dustin Mades,
brave warrior and a Cherokee and actually, you know,
join the army up and go over to Iraq. I'm like, wow, I'm here for the Cherokees.
I'm the brave warrior out in, you know, desert.
He's been a registered members since he was a little kid.
His parents were members and their parents and he said he's proud to be Cherokee
basically because it means that he's from where he lives. It's a big deal to me.
So anyway, we started talking about the case and you know, it gets complicated.
There's a lot of detail. I'm not going to go into all of it,
but basically he and Christie Maldonado, the birth mom,
we've known each other since we were 16. We've dated off and on through 2008,
he joins the army basic training. He lives on a base.
It's four hours away or south of Christmas time that year.
He basically says, let's get serious. Got down on one knee and proposed to her,
said, hey, I want to bring you into my life. She said, okay, that's just great.
And almost a month later she'd send me a message saying that she was pregnant
and I was excited. I mean, I have children,
but her was, I was one of the things I wanted at that time.
Told her I can move you in your kids up to the base.
Housing was going to be free on base. There was schools for her kids,
she could get a job right there on base, you know, everything was taken care of.
I mean everything was going great, you know,
and then pretty quickly the whole thing just soured.
It's impossible to know exactly what happened.
But Christy says that Dustin just simply didn't offer any support.
He says that he did here. He tried to at least,
but shortly after she got pregnant, she basically just shut him out,
just stop taking his calls. I didn't get no phone calls, no text messages,
none from rather blue. And I'm just like, well, what's going on?
And he says that he tried to get in touch with her detection,
trying to call her. You're still no answer. Uh,
there's a couple of times that I've went back to the bars. I went to her house,
drove those four hours from the base, knocked on a door. I could hear, you know,
voices in the house. It sounded like her and the kids,
they wouldn't answer the door for me. And then one day he says,
she sent me a message saying, I don't want to be with you no more.
In three weeks after that, she's like, well, I want you to sign your rights over
[inaudible]
his parental rights. Would you sign your rights over? You guys are texting this,
are you talking? Oh,
the whole time we're text messaging this because she wouldn't talk to me.
And what did you think it meant to me? How does that,
she wanted me to sign my rights over her and I'm like,
this something I really don't want to do. He says,
she kept texting him that question and looming in his mind was the fact that
he'd just learned that we were going to be going to Iraq to do a radar mission.
So he starts to wonder, what's the right thing to do here? You know,
there was one chances I wasn't gonna come back.
I wanted to make the right choice and let the mother be that sole parent and he
says that he's holding out hope that if he does make it back,
we'll get back together and she'll just change your mind. Finally,
I just told her, I was like, all right, I'll sign my rights over months go by.
Christie has the baby,
he says he doesn't know exactly when because they weren't speaking.
But then six days before I had to go deploy to Iraq,
I get a phone call from some guy in Washington county. The process server said,
hey, we need you to sign some papers, so sign your custody rights over nick.
I directed him to an office right near the base.
We went there and signed the paper.
And what did you think it meant the whole time? I thought I was just, you know,
the paperwork for me signing custody rights to her,
but when I got done sign, the guy said,
you just signed your rights away and instead of the biological mother,
the baby's been up for adoption.
She'd been living in South Carolina for four months.
[inaudible]
Dustin says,
this is the first moment that he realized what was actually happening,
that the baby was up for adoption and he says that he had no idea he had just
legally consented to it.
I should've had a lawyer there with me at that point in time.
I grabbed the paper
[inaudible]
when the guy looked at me and said, if you go on, rip that up. He said, it's,
you can, it's not good to do that. That he could be arrested. And I said,
what do I got to do? He said, you get a lawyer,
which he immediately did.
And that's why the courts have ruled in his favor because they say that from
that moment, he's clearly demonstrated that he wants to be her dad. I mean,
I never, never once did I want to give up on my daughter. Never wants to,
I didn't want to give her up. I mean, everybody says that I gave her up.
I never wanted to. Now mark and Laurie say that if this were any other guy,
any other man of any other race, the story would be over right about here.
It's too late.
He wouldn't have any rights at all under every state's laws too late under the
federal constitution. Too late. He rejected that opportunity to become a father.
But he has one thing in his favor, says, Lord, he happens to be [inaudible]
Cherokee. And because of that fact,
not only can this sort of man object,
but he gets an automatic transfer of custody to him. And Mark and Laura,
you see that as basically the worst kind of preferential treatment and that is
unbelievable. This is John John Nichols.
This is Shannon Shannon Jones and the two of Dustin's lawyers. And John says,
okay, there's preferential treatment. Fine, but,
but think about why all the protections of equal are there.
These roadblocks are there for a reason. We went over this earlier,
but you know, basically people are being manipulated out of their kids.
And while you might like to think that that's ancient history.
Now fast forward to 2010 he says the same thing is happening in this case and we
have a registered member of the Cherokee nation.
We have his child being given up for adoption without his knowledge and without
his consent.
And they kept this adoption from him for months and then spring it on him six
days before he leaves the country. It,
it looks to us like it was engineered to make sure he got served,
but not in enough time to where he could put up a fight.
I believe it was absolutely intentional and Shannon suggests that they knew
about Equa, they knew it would apply and they were trying to sidestep.
There were so many errors. You just did a little air quotes on errors. Yeah,
I did. Because I mean like for example,
there's this one important forum where Shannon says that they went out of their
way to make it look like Veronica is not native Americans.
Cause it would be detrimental to the adoption. That's just, um,
it's a preposterous argument.
You know the form mark and lawyers say the reason that nobody puts Cherokee and
big bright flaming letters is simple. Christie herself is predominantly,
Dustin is predominantly Caucasian and is approximately 2% Cherokee.
What did you say? 2% yeah.
Veronica herself would be a little bit over one person. Wait,
this whole thing is happening because he's only 2% I feel like that changes
things somehow. Well, yeah,
but you have to keep in mind that Cherokee nation doesn't care about the
percentage of Cherokee in your blood.
That's not how they determine their members.
Being a member of the Cherokee nation is like being a member of the United
States. You are a citizen of the nation.
You know, if, if your parents a US citizen, you're automatically a citizen.
That's Chrissy Nimo, assistant attorney general for Cherokee nation.
If your parents a Cherokee citizen, you're not automatically a citizen,
but you can automatically apply. So it's based on direct lineage.
But still, you're right,
because this is the argument that is most troubling to the tribes.
Both Chrissy Nimo and marsh [inaudible] told me that if the supreme court ends
up deciding that Equa is unconstitutional because it really is rice-based
unconstitutional because it's a race based preference.
It calls into question every single federal Indian law out there goes Indian
law. This is a case that they could use to do that.
Mm.
If equal falls because it's unconstitutional,
it could have a crazy domino effect.
Every single federal Indian law is premised on giving some sort of special
treatment to Indians.
[inaudible]
what would that mean concretely if Indian law were to go away?
It means that they are policing their court system, their education,
anything they do as a sovereign nation, all of that just evaporates. Eh,
you know, like a,
a tribe would just become another group of people on some land
[inaudible]
that said, this is not the likely outcome.
Now the supreme court will probably rule as narrowly as they possibly can and as
far as the tribes are concerned,
they can do a lot of damage to the law without calling it unconstitutional.
You know, they could allow for this certain kind of exception to Iqua,
which would make it a lot easier for people like the capital Bianco's to adopt.
So they could rule any number of ways. Yeah,
and the thing is that it's all strangely connected to this.
I figured three year old girl and holds onto this.
I'm thinking I'm just gonna sign custody rights over. So when,
when she finally showed up halfway through my interview, right.
Dustin? Hello. Hi.
It was kind of surreal daughter Ronica though.
Hey Veronica, I'm Tim.
She's got dark curly hair. She's this ball of energy.
She's definitely bullheaded.
And within a minute she's given me a tour of every single object in her room.
Yes. I mean everything. I'm the bear army bear.
I don't want to carry dog tags on it. She was a very,
I'm a very proud, cool hosts.
A few minutes later, if she wanted to show me her geese,
I don't think I've seen geese in a long time. What can tell me about it too?
Those are, those are real [inaudible]. Yeah,
correct.
She feeds them out of her hand.
Nope. Nope. Don't mess with that water.
Maybe
Thomas the train. Yeah. So, uh, what, what could happen to her?
Are they eating? Well, if the Supreme Court said
Grant Dustin Brown shouldn't have qualified, um, as father under equity,
what they do is they would send it back down to a South Carolina court and then
they would have this new best interest evaluation basically.
Like what's the best thing for her at this point?
She's been with him now for about a year and a half.
And so that actually might really change the calculation,
you know,
and I want to try honestly hanging out with her and Dustin in the backyard.
It's really easy to forget all these people whose lives are just completely
tangled up in this scene. But who aren't there?
Christie Maldonado, the birth mom, she did not intend to get Veronica.
She intended to give Veronica a life. Matt and Melanie Capobianco. I mean,
this has been going on for so long.
We'd kind of been in a holding pattern for like, well forever.
We're just waiting and waiting and waiting. And of course the,
the hundreds of tribes who are just worried about their own kids.
Pretty cool. Are you a good swimmer? Yes. Hi Dad.
Smeller I'm a bad swimmer.
Simmer. No, I'm a pretty bad swimmer. No,
you're not your dad's name or how do you know I'm a good swimmer?
Dad's Manet. Your Dad's mailer. Well,
I appreciate that.
Yeah. The secret.
So the Supreme Court came to a decision on this ruling about a month after we
first aired this podcast and here's what they said.
Okay. So, uh, the supreme court ruled five,
four in favor of the adoptive couple,
which is to say against the birth father to Dustin Brown. The Dad lost, right?
It was like a 60 ruling
and not being totally confident with all the ramifications where I just made
some calls.
Hi, how are you?
I'm doing great. How are you [inaudible] for example, I skyped with Marsha Zog,
who you remember from the piece.
She's a law professor at the University of South Carolina.
Can you walk me through what this opinion means?
Well in terms of Veronica's placement,
had it come out the other way, then it would be over.
She would stay with Dustin Brown, her biological father, end of story.
What we have now is the court upholding the termination of his parental rights.
So basically the supreme court ruled that Dustin Brown shouldn't have been
allowed to invoke the Indian child welfare act because he didn't have what's
called continuing custody of Veronica continuing custody. Right.
They argue that this is about preventing the breakup of Indian families and
there was no Indian family here because they didn't live together.
The Dad and the daughter didn't lived, right. Yeah.
So they don't scrap the Indian Child Welfare Act.
They just say that it shouldn't apply in a case like this. So basically,
according to Tim, it was a pretty narrow ruling.
What then happened is that the supreme court kicked the case down to a lower
court in South Carolina and that lower court ultimately awarded custody of
Veronica to the Kappa Bianco's. Dustin Brown tried to fight it.
There were lots of lawsuits flying back and forth in both directions,
but in the end, Veronica did end up going to the Campo Bianco's.
Then two and a half weeks since our daughter, Veronica [inaudible],
Matt Millichap Bianca,
and on October 10th, 2013 Dustin Brown called depress comp.
It was the love for my daughter that kept me going all this time,
but it's not.
It was also the love from my daughter did that finally gave me the strength to
accept things that are beyond my control.
The time has come for me to let Veronica live in normal childhood.
It was so desperately needed and deserves.
Dustin Brown then announced that he would be stopping his custody battle.
That's good. And to Veronica, one day,
you will read about this time in your life. Never, ever,
ever for one second.
[inaudible] never ever for one second. Now how much I love you
[inaudible]. How hard I fought for you. How much do you mean doing
[inaudible]?
My home will always be your home. I'm always welcome in it.
[inaudible]
I miss you more than words can express.
Yeah,
there will always be my little girl,
my princess and I will always love you until the day I die.
One more thing in our story,
we talked a lot about the possibility,
sort of the larger possibility that from the tribe's perspective this case could
be used as a first step to basically declare Indian law as a race based
situation that
could then be negated. That didn't happen in this case,
but there is this sense that they, they kind of planted a seed.
For example, Justice Alito who wrote the ruling,
he starts it off with mention of Veronica being, you know,
a 1.2% Cherokee. Hmm.
Which is interesting cause it sounds like he's about to make an argument for why
this is a race-based preference and why it's a violation of equal protection.
But then he doesn't make that argument. He pulls back according to Tim.
And so the question is why did he start the ruling that way?
Was he trying to send a message of some kind?
I asked Marsha what she thought about it.
Why do you think they started it off that way?
I have been thinking about that. Um, [inaudible]
it clearly
sat wrong with at least some members of the court.
I mean when listening to the oral arguments, you could tell that, you know,
Robert's harped on it as well.
I think it's an indication that at least some members of the court have serious
reservations about Indian law because they just don't see Veronica as an Indian
child. To them,
a Indian is a race and she doesn't have enough blood to be of that race.
And I would say so possible indication of where future Indian law cases are
going to go.
No.
[inaudible]
since then,
the supreme court has seen a handful of Indian law cases and the biggest
development so far is that the bureau of Indian affairs and the federal
government have changed the rules surrounding the Indian Child Welfare Act or
thereabout. You, the new rule changes are gonna go into effect December, 2016.
What it will mean is that when a child like Veronica is put up for adoption,
the state would have to ask whether or not she was an Indian child.
The father would have to been asked whether or not she was an Indian child and
the state would not be able to consider what percentage Indian blood she has in
determining if she is an Indian child.
Obviously the hope is that future Veronica's will not have to go through what
this Veronica went through, but we'll see. Huge thanks to Tim Howard,
uh, who now produces the amazing podcast reply all.
They just put out a four part series on the criminal justice system.
It's called on the inside. Definitely check it out.
At the time we made this episode, radio lab was produced by myself,
Jenna Boon Rod, our staff includes the amazing Robert Krulwich, Ellen horns,
Soren wheeler, Tim Howard, Brenna feral, Molly Webster, Melissa O'Donnell,
Dylan Keefe, Lynn Levy, Andy Mills.